WE WILL SEE YOU TOMORROW.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THANK YOU FOR WATCHING.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
IN CASE YOU HAVEN’T NOTICED,
IT’S HARD TO TRUST ANYTHING YOU
HEAR RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE GRATEFUL YOU TRUST US AND
WE WILL TRY TO BE WORTHY OF YOUR
TRUST.
WE WANT TO BEGIN BY ASSESSING
SOME OF THE THINGS NO DOUBT YOU
HAVE HEARD ABOUT LAST WEEK’S
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION,
CONFLICTING VERSIONS OF EVERY
PART OF THAT STORY.
BUT AS OF RIGHT NOW, HERE’S WHAT
WE THINK WE KNOW.
FOR MUCH OF ELECTION NIGHT,
DONALD TRUMP SEEM TO BE LEADING
IN A NUMBER OF KEY SWING STATES,
THAN EARLY WEDNESDAY MORNING, HE
BEGAN TO FALL BEHIND.
THAT TREND CONTINUED MORE OR
LESS FOR SEVERAL DAYS AND
SATURDAY, THE MEDIA DECLARED
JOE BIDEN THE PRESIDENT-ELECT.
BIDEN QUICKLY ACCEPTED THAT
JUDGMENT.
THEY NOW HAVE SOMETHING CALLED
THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT.
SOUNDS OFFICIAL WHICH IS THE
POINT OF SUDDEN GET UP IN THE
END, IT’S POSSIBLE IT WILL BE
OFFICIAL IF AFTER ALL THE
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ANSWERED IT
BECOMES CLEAR THAT JOE BIDEN IS
A LEGITIMATE WINNER OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, WE WILL
ACCEPT THAT AND ENCOURAGE OTHERS
TO ACCEPT IT TOO.
WE ARE AMERICANS FIRST AND WE
WANT WHAT IT’S BEST FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
WE WANT OUR SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT
TO CONTINUE.
WHETHER IT DOES CONTINUE DEPENDS
ON HOW WE PROCEED FROM HERE.
AS OF TONIGHT, TENS OF MILLIONS
OF AMERICANS SUSPECT THIS
ELECTION WAS STOLEN FROM THEM.
THAT MEANS WE NOW LIVE IN A
COUNTRY WHERE A LARGE PERCENTAGE
OF OUR POPULATION NO LONGER
BELIEVES OUR DEMOCRACY IS REAL.
THAT IS SAD AND DANGEROUS AND
CAN GET WORSE.
WHAT WE ARE DOING IN RESPONSE IS
HARDLY THE SOLUTION.
IS MAKING OUR COUNTRY MUCH MORE
VOLATILE AND SETTING US UP FOR
SOMETHING BAD.
IN A DEMOCRACY, YOU CAN’T IGNORE
HONEST QUESTIONS FROM CITIZENS.
YOU CAN’T DISMISS THEM OUT OF
HAND IS CRAZY OR IMMORAL FOR
ASKING.
YOU CAN’T JUST CUT AWAY FROM
COVERAGE YOU DON’T LIKE.
YOU CAN’T TELL PEOPLE TO ACCEPT
AN OUTCOME BECAUSE FORCE DOESN’T
WORK IN A DEMOCRACY.
THAT’S DICTATORSHIP.
IN A FREE SOCIETY, YOU HAVE TO
CONVINCE THE PUBLIC OF YOUR
LEGITIMACY.
YOU HAVE TO WIN THEM OVER WITH
REASON.
DEMOCRACY IS ALWAYS A VOLUNTARY
ARRANGEMENT.
TELLING VOTERS TO SHUT UP IS
NEVER ENOUGH.
SO IN THIS CASE TONIGHT, THERE’S
ONLY ONE WAY TO LOWER THE
NATIONAL TEMPERATURE IN THE
NIGHT THE COUNTRY.
YOU NEED TO FIND OUT EXACTLY
WHAT HAPPENED IN THIS ELECTION.
AND THERE ARE QUESTIONS AND THAT
MEANS WE HAVE TO ANSWER THEM.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN PENNSYLVANIA,
NEVADA, AND MICHIGAN, NOW
COLLECTING THE SIGNED AFFIDAVITS
THAT A TEST OF CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
DURING THE VOTING PROCESS.
WITNESSES HAVE ALLEGED UNDER
OATH THAT BALLOTS WERE
IMPROPERLY BACKDATED AND COUNTED
WITHOUT MATCHING SIGNATURES.
ONE POLL WATCHER ALLEGES THAT
40,000 LATE UNSEALED ABSENTEE
BALLOTS WERE COUNTED ORALLY AND
ALL OF THEM WERE FOR DEMOCRATS.
IN THE STATE OF NEVADA, EIGHT
WHISTLE-BLOWERS FROM WITHIN THE
NEVADA ELECTION DEPARTMENT SAY
THEY WITNESSED VOTER FRAUD
ABETTED BY OTHER ELECTION
OFFICIALS AND BY THEIR
SUPERVISORS.
ACCORDING TO ONE AFFIDAVIT, SOME
PEOPLE GIVING HANDFULS OF
BALLOTS AND THEY WERE THEN
FILLED OUT AND PLACED IN RETURN
ENVELOPES.
EVENTUALLY, BITE AND SUPPORTERS
FORMED A WALL TO BLOCK OUTSIDERS
FROM SEEING WHAT THEY WERE DOING
DOING.
MEANWHILE ACCORDING TO VOTING
RECORDS, PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT EVEN
ALIVE STILL SOMEHOW MANAGED TO
VOTE ON TUESDAY.
IN NEW YORK, DECEASED VOTERS
CAST ABSENTEE BALLOTS.
IN NEVADA, A MAN CALLED FRED
STOKES JR. MAILED HIS VOTE AND
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS HE DIED
THREE YEARS AGO AT THE AGE OF
92.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY OF NEVADA
SAYS IT IS AWARE OF HUNDREDS OF
OTHER POTENTIAL CASES OF DEAD
PEOPLE CASTING BALLOTS.
IN PENNSYLVANIA, RECORD SHOWED
TURNOUT FROM SEVERAL PEOPLE BORN
IN THE 19TH CENTURY THAT
APPARENTLY ROSE FROM THEIR
GRAVES TO VOTE.
ALL OF THAT IS REAL.
WE SPENT ALL WEEKEND CHECKING
AT.
FALSE CLAIMS OF FRAUD CAN BE
EVERY BIT AS DESTRUCTIVE AS THE
FRAUD ITSELF SO WE NEED TO BE
CAREFUL AND RESPONSIBLE, ALL OF
US.
BUT WHAT WE JUST TOLD YOU IS
TRUE AND THERE IS MORE OF IT.
JUST HOURS AGO IN THE STATE OF
GEORGIA, AND ELECTION OFFICIAL
ADMITTED THEY FOUND DOUBLE
VOTERS WHEN THEY CHECK THE VOTER
ROLLS.
>> LET ME BE PERFECTLY CLEAR ON
ANOTHER POINT.
WE ARE GOING TO FIND THAT PEOPLE
DID A LEGALLY VOTE.
THAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN.
THEY WERE GOING TO BE DOUBLE
VOTERS, PEOPLE THAT DID NOT HAVE
THE QUALIFICATIONS TO VOTE IN
THE STATE.
THAT WILL BE FOUND.
IF IT’S 10,353, UNLIKELY, BUT
EVERY ELECTION AS I’VE SAID I
THINK EVERY DAY AT THIS PODIUM
IS IMPERFECT.
>> Tucker: WE ARE GOING TO
FIND THAT PEOPLE DID LEGALLY
VOTE, THAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN.
THAT IS THE OFFICIAL ACCOUNT
BEFORE EVEN COUNTING THE VOTES
FROM A KEY SWING STATE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A CONTESTED ELECTION.
AND OF COURSE, YOU CAN BELIEVE
IT BECAUSE WE’VE ALREADY FOUND
ILLEGAL VOTING.
SO MUCH FOR THOSE CLAIMS THAT
VOTER FRAUD NEVER HAPPENS.
OF COURSE IT HAPPENS, THEY KNEW
WOULD HAPPEN WHEN THEY TOLD US
IT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN BECAUSE
THEY ARE LIARS SO WE KNOW THAT
FOR SURE.
AT THIS STAGE, THE FRAUD THAT WE
CAN CONFIRM DOES NOT SEEM TO BE
ENOUGH TO ALTER THE ELECTION
RESULTS.
WE SHOULD BE HONEST AND TELL YOU
THAT.
OF COURSE, THAT CAN CHANGE.
BUT CHANGING THE ELECTION
RESULTS IS NOT THE WHOLE POINT.
THE REAL POINT IS THAT FRAUD
TOOK PLACE AND THAT SHOULD
HORRIFY US.
IF YOU WANT TO BELIEVE THAT OUR
SYSTEM IS REAL AND WORTH SAY
JOINING THE MILITARY AND DYING
TO PROTECT, THEN YOU’VE GOT TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT JUST
HAPPENED AND YOU’VE GOT TO DO IT
AS QUICKLY AND RESPONSIBLY AS
YOU CAN.
YOU CAN’T HAVE FRAUD IN AN
ELECTION BECAUSE NO ONE WOULD
BELIEVE IN ELECTIONS AND THEN
THINGS FALL APART.
THE GATHERING FACTS IS THE LAST
THING OUR MEDIA ARE DESIGNATED
FACT GATHERERS SEEM TO WANT TO
DO.
INSTEAD, THEY ARE DEMANDING YOU
SHUT UP AND ACCEPT JOE BIDEN.
AND IF THAT YOU DON’T ACCEPT IT,
THOUGH HER EAR.
IN OTHER WORDS, NO ONE IN THIS
COUNTRY IS GOING TO SET UP A
RESISTANCE TO JOE BIDEN.
THEY WILL MAKE CERTAIN OF THAT.
THOSE ARE FOR RANGE ROVER’S
ONLY, NO PICKUP TRUCKS ALLOWED.
TRY AND YOU’LL FIND OUT.
OVERSTATEMENT?
THIS MORNING, A PROMINENT ANCHOR
ON CNN SENT THIS TWEET TO TRUMP
SUPPORTER’S.
"I TRULY SYMPATHIZE WITH THOSE
DEALING WITH LOSING BUT AT A
CERTAIN POINT, ONE HAS TO THINK
NOT ONLY ABOUT WHAT’S BEST FOR
THE NATION, BUT HOW ANY FUTURE
EMPLOYERS MIGHT SEE YOUR
CHARACTER DEFINED DURING
ADVERSITY.
THIS GOT THAT?
YOUR CHARACTER IS ON TRIAL HERE.
FUTURE EMPLOYERS, TAKE NOTE.
IN OTHER WORDS, ACCEPT JOE BIDEN
NOW OR YOU WILL NEVER WORK
AGAIN, DO WHAT CNN TELLS YOU TO
DO HER GOOD LUCK FEEDING YOUR
FAMILY.
DID THE SICILIAN MAFIA EVER MAKE
THREATS THAT EXPLICIT?
KNOW, BECAUSE THEY KNEW THE FBI
WAS LISTENING BUT IN THIS CASE,
THE ENTIRE MEDIA ESTABLISHMENT.
AFTER JOE BIDEN CLAIMED VICTORY
ON SATURDAY, CNN RELEASED AN AD
DEMANDING ITS VIEWERS TO ACCEPT
JOE BIDEN AS THEIR LAWFUL
PRESIDENT AND HOLY SAVIOR.
YOU DON’T LET JOE BIDEN INTO
YOUR HEART MOTHER CANNOT BE
PEACE.
A WATCH.
>> OUR TRUST HAS BEEN BROKEN,
AND THEIR LEADERS, AND OUR
INSTITUTIONS, EVEN WITH SOME OF
OUR FRIENDS.
AND WE ARE HURTING.
NOW MORE THAN EVER, WE NEED EACH
OTHER TO LISTEN, TO LEARN FROM
ONE ANOTHER, TO REBUILD THOSE
BONDS.
>> Tucker: IT’S OVER, NOW’S
THE TIME TO COME TOGETHER, NOW’S
THE TIME FOR HEALING OR ELSE.
SO WHAT EXACTLY IS THIS HEALING
THAT THEY ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
AND COMMANDING YOU TO
PARTICIPATE IN?
AND HER MESSAGE OF UNITY,
MICHELLE OBAMA RODE "LET’S
REMEMBER THAT TENS OF MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE VOTED FOR THE
STATUS QUO EVEN WHEN IT MEANT
SUPPORTING ALLIES, HATE, CHAOS
COMMIT AND DIVISION.
"THAT’S THE UNITY MESSAGE.
LET’S REMEMBER WHO DISOBEYED AND
LET’S HURT THEM.
LET’S REMEMBER THE PEOPLE THAT
VOTED FOR A POLITICAL OPPONENT.
SANDY CORTEZ AND WESTCHESTER
DIDN’T NEED TO BE REMINDED
BECAUSE SHE HADN’T FORGOTTEN.
ASKED "IS ANYONE ARCHIVING THESE
TRUMPS
TRUMPSTRUMP SYCOPHANTS FOR WHEN
TRY TO DOWNPLAY IN THE FUTURE?
"SHE’S RIDING THEM HERSELF.
THE ANSWER OF COURSE THAT
QUESTION IS ANYONE KEEPING TRACK
OF THE TRUMP SUPPORTER’S YOU
MUST BE PUNISHED IS YES, SOMEONE
IS KEEPING TRACK.
THE FORMER NATIONAL PRESS
SECRETARY FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE AND FORMER
PETE BUTTIGIEG STAFFER WAS
ALREADY HARD AT WORK ON AND ON
MY ENEMIES LIST AND RODE
"WHITE HOUSE STAFFERS STARTING
TO LOOK FOR JOBS, EMPLOYERS
CONSIDERING THEM SHOULD KNOW
THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES FOR
HIRING ANYONE WHO HELPED TRUMP
ATTACK AMERICAN VALUES."
OH, AMERICAN VALUES, SAID THE
GUY WHO’S GOING FULL SOVIET.
TOTALLY IMPERVIOUS TO IRONY,
THESE PEOPLE.
IN CORPORATE OF COURSE WAS ON
BOARD, THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE,
REPUBLICAN GROUPS ALONG WITH
CEOs FROM COMPANIES LIKE
UNITED AIRLINES, MICROSOFT, YOU
NAME THEM.
ALREADY CONGRATULATED JOE BIDEN
AS THE ACCOUNTING WAS STILL
UNDERWAY AND AS THEY WERE DOING
THAT, THE MEDIA WERE NOT HARD AT
WORK VERIFYING THE INTEGRITY OF
THE ELECTION AND DEMOCRACY THEY
SO DEEPLY CHERISHED, WORTH
INTERVIEWING THE POLL WORKERS
WHO SIGN THOSE AFFIDAVITS, WHICH
ARE REAL.
>> HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
>> I ALMOST CAN’T TALK RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE OF THE EMOTION.
EVERYONE IS WELCOME UNDER THIS
TENS.
WE DON’T CARE WHO YOU ARE.
WE DON’T CARE IF YOU VOTED FOR
US OR NOT.
YOU ARE ALL PART OF THIS
AMERICAN EXPERIMENT.
I WAS SO OVERWHELMED TO HEAR
THAT.
I DON’T CARE WHAT PEOPLE THINK,
I DON’T CARE.
SO I’M VERY EMOTIONAL SO WHEN
YOU ASK ME HOW I’M FEELING RIGHT
NOW, I’M SORRY, THAT’S ALL I CAN
TELL YOU, THIS IS HOW I FEEL
RIGHT NOW.
I AM SO HAPPY TO HAVE THIS
PLATFORM AND I MAY NOT HAVE IT
AFTER THIS BUT I REALLY DON’T
CARE.
I AM SO HAPPY.
>> Tucker: I DON’T CARE.
TAKE IT FROM SOMEONE WHO DOES
THIS GIG FOR A LIVING.
YOU CAN’T KEEP YOUR EMOTIONS IN
CHECK TO THINK CLEARLY, YOU ARE
A CHILD, DO SOMETHING ELSE.
I DON’T CARE IF PEOPLE THINK I’M
BIASED OR NOT, THERE YOU GO, AND
THEY REALLY DON’T CARE BECAUSE
THEY DON’T NEED TO BECAUSE THEY
WON OR CLAIM THEY DO.
LIKE ALL HASTY DECISIONS, WE
WILL REGRET IT.
HAVE YOU EVER MADE A HASTY
DECISION YOU HAD TO LIVE WITH
LONG-TERM?
NO, YOU HAVE THEM.
THE POINT ISN’T THAT WE KEEP
INVESTIGATING UNTIL DONALD TRUMP
WINS PAIR THAT IS NOT THE POINT.
THE POINT IS WE NEED TO FIND OUT
WHAT HAPPENED SO THE REST OF US
BELIEVE THE SYSTEM IS REAL AND
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN, CONGRESS
NEEDS TO INVESTIGATE EVERY
MEANINGFUL CLAIM OF ILLEGAL
VOTING, EVERY LEGITIMATE CLAIM
MUST BE INVESTIGATED.
THAT BECOME A CIRCUS?
OF COURSE.
WOULD IT DESCEND TO PARTISAN
POSTURING?
GUARANTEED.
BUT THERE’S NO CHOICE.
IT’S STILL WORTH IT.
AN INVESTIGATION LIKE THAT WOULD
PRODUCE FACTS, AND WE NEED FACTS
FACTS.
TRANSPARENCY IS THE KEY AND
WITHOUT IT, THERE’S NO HOPE.
EVER WONDER WHY PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES ARE EMBRACING CONSPIRACY
THEORIES?
YOU CAN’T JUST MAKE THEM GO AWAY
OR SHUT DOWN THE WEB SITES,
PEOPLE REACH FOR THAT.
MY?
BECAUSE THEY KNOW PEOPLE TELLING
THE OFFICIAL STORY ARE LYING AND
THEY ARE LYING.
IN THE MOMENT THEY TRY TO GET
REAL ANSWERS FROM THE PEOPLE IN
CHARGE, HERE’S WHAT HAPPENS.
>> ALL OF YOU SUCK IT UP.
SUCK IT UP LIKE WE SUCKED IT UP
AND IF YOU’RE NOT SURE THAT
YOU’RE COMFORTABLE WITH
JOE BIDEN, DO WHAT WE DID.
FIND THINGS AND THEN TAKE IT TO
THE LAW AND OF THE LAW SAYS IT’S
SOMETHING TO LOOK AT, LOOK AT IT
BUT FROM NOW ON, SUCK IT UP.
GROW THE PAIR.
FOR HIM THAT HE CAN’T GROW FOR
HIMSELF.
BECAUSE THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
YOU’RE NOT SURE THAT HE WON.
YOU BRINGING IN THE QUESTION ALL
THESE AMERICANS WHO VOTED
LEGALLY CAME OUT AND STOOD AND
VOTED, HOW DARE YOU QUESTION IT?
>> Tucker: THE UNHAPPIEST
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD HAVE ALL THE
POWER AND HOW DARE YOU QUESTION
IT?
HOW DARE YOU ASK WHY DEAD PEOPLE
ARE VOTING?
HOW DARE YOU QUESTION THE
DECISION DESK, WHO ARE YOU?
THEIR CONTEMPT ALL ALONG IS
PRINT COMPLETELY OUT OF HAND.
YOU WON’T ADMIT THAT JOE BIDEN
IS THE PRESIDENT EVEN THOUGH
VOTES ARE STILL BEING COUNTED,
GUESS WHAT YOU ARE?
YOU SAW THIS COMING, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
YOU’RE A RACIST.
>> MORE WHITE PEOPLE VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP IN 2020 THAN THEY
DID IN 2016.
SO THE RECKONING THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING AS A NATION AT
LEAST IN MY MIND SHOWS US THAT
HER RACE, SELFISHNESS, GREED
CONTINUED TO THREATEN THE VERY
LIFE OF OUR REPUBLIC.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE, RACISM,
SAYS THE PRINCETON PROFESSOR.
NOT A SURPRISE, THAT’S ALWAYS
THE ANSWER WHEN THEY WANT TO
FORCE YOU TO BE QUIET.
IS THERE A SHELF LIFE ON THIS?
HOW LONG TO THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE
THINK THEY CAN CONTINUE MAKING
THE SAME PLAY AGAIN AND AGAIN
AND AGAIN?
HOW LONG CAN THE MOST PRIVILEGED
PEOPLE IN OUR SOCIETY AND
PRORATE THOSE BENEATH THEM INTO
SILENCE FROM THEIR PURCHASE ON
CABLE NEWS?
THEY PROBABLY IMAGINE THEY CAN
DO IT FOREVER, BUT THEY’RE
WRONG.
IT CAN’T LAST, NOTHING THIS
GROTESQUE GOES ON FOREVER.
AT SOME POINT, IT WILL END.
WE HOPE THE SYSTEM WON’T EXPLODE
AT THAT POINT, BUT THAT’S WHERE
WE ARE GOING.
SO WHAT’S THE SOLUTION?
HOW DO WE FIX IT AND BRING THE
COUNTRY TOGETHER?
HOW DO WE MAKE IN AMERICA YOU
WANT TO LIVE IN?
THE ONLY ANSWER, THE ONLY
SOLUTION IS HONESTY.
LET’S ALL STOP LYING.
LYING ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT
MATTERS EVERY DAY OF OUR LIVES,
THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE DOING NOW.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU LIGHT
TODAY BECAUSE YOU HAD TO?
LET’S REPEAL OUR NATIONAL
DISHONESTY MANDATE.
ALONG NEVER CODIFIED BUT STILL
RUTHLESSLY ENFORCE AND TELL THE
TRUTH INSTEAD.
THAT’S OUR ONLY HOPE, TELL THE
TRUTH ABOUT EVERYTHING.
YOU CLASSIFY THE DOCUMENTS, NOTE
THE OBVIOUS RIGHT IN FRONT OF
YOU, GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT
ALL.
WHY SHOULDN’T WE DO THAT?
WHAT WE’RE DOING NOW CLEARLY
ISN’T WORKING, AND FORCED LYING
IS MAKING EVERYONE PARANOID AND
CRAZY.
TRUTH CANNOT BE WORSE THAN WHAT
WE ARE LIVING THROUGH NOW.
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS WE
SHOULD BE HONEST ABOUT THIS AT
THE WORST FORMS OF ELECTION
TAMPERING TOOK PLACE FAR FROM
POLLING SITES.
WASN’T VOTES FROM DEAD PEOPLE.
THOSE ARE BAD, BUT THEY WEREN’T
THE WORST THING FOR THE WORST
THING WAS MORE OBVIOUS THAN
THAT.
THE WORST THING WAS
SILICON VALLEY, THE TECH
MONOPOLY SPENT THE FINAL WEEKS
SUPPRESSING THE VOICES OF TRUMP
SUPPORTER’S AND HIDING DAMAGING
INFORMATION ABOUT HIS OPPONENT
JOE BIDEN.
THAT HAPPEN.
WE SAW IT FIRSTHAND, WE
EXPERIENCED IT, YOU MAY HAVE
TOO.
IN AUGUST, FACEBOOK BANNED THE
PRO-TRUMP SUPER PAC COMMITTEE
FROM BUYING ANY CAMPAIGN
ADVERTISING.
WHAT ELECTION HAS THAT HAPPENED
IN?
NONE FOR JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO AS
YOU WELL KNOW,
"THE NEW YORK POST" PUBLISHED
TRUE AND ACCURATE DETAILS OF THE
BIDEN FAMILIES LUCRATIVE
OVERSEAS PEDALING OPERATION
WHICH WAS REAL AND JOE BIDEN
KNEW ABOUT.
FACEBOOK, IN TURN, LIMITED THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THIS ARTICLE AND
TWITTER BLOCKED PEOPLE, THEY
KEPT PEOPLE FROM KNOWING ABOUT
IT AND ON WHAT BASIS?
NOTHING IN THOSE ARTICLES WAS
UNTRUE BUT THEY CENSORED IT
ANYWAY ALONG WITH ANY CONTENT
THAT WAS CRITICAL OF LOCKDOWNS
AND MANDATORY MASK WEARING.
MY?
BECAUSE BIDEN SUPPORTED THOSE.
AND THERE ARE MANY THREADS TO
THIS, OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE THIS
HAPPENS, A REPORT FROM BREITBART
TOOK A LOT OF TIME LOOKING AT
WHAT GOOGLE WAS DOING TO THEM
AND FOUND THAT GOOGLE SUPPRESSED
ITS STORIES ABOUT JOE BIDEN IN
THE MIDDLE OF 2020 THROUGH
ELECTION DAY, SUPPRESS THEM.
"CLICKS AND IMPRESSIONS TO
BREITBART NEWS FROM JOE BIDEN
GOOGLE SEARCHES DISPLAYED A
HEALTHY PATTERN OF ACTIVITY INTO
THE MIDDLE OF 2020 WHEN THEY
SUDDENLY FLATLINED.
THE PLUNGE FIRST OCCURRED AFTER
A MAJOR UPDATE TO GOOGLE’S
SEARCH ALGORITHM IN MAY 2020.
ASK ANYBODY IN DIGITAL NEWS, DO
SEARCHES FOR THE NAMES OF
CANDIDATES DECLINE AS WE GET
CLOSER TO THE ELECTION?
PROBABLY NOT.
IN FACT, THEY ACCELERATE, BUT
NOT IF GOOGLE IS CENSORING YOU,
WHICH IS WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
NONE OF THIS IS NORMAL.
DOESN’T MATTER HOW OFTEN OR HOW
EMPHATICALLY CNN ENCOURAGES IT
AND TELLS YOU IT’S FINE AND
NECESSARY TO SUPPRESS
DISINFORMATION, IS TOTALLY
WRONG, AND IT’S CRAZY.
DEMOCRACY CANNOT SURVIVE
TAMPERING LIKE THAT.
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN KNOWS EXACTLY
WHAT HAPPENED AND THEY KNOW
EXACTLY THE DEGREE TO WHICH THEY
BENEFITED FROM IT AND THAT’S WHY
THEY ARE REWARDING THEIR
COCONSPIRATORS AND BIG TEX WITH
EVEN MORE POWER.
BIDEN APPARENTLY HAS ALREADY
HIRED JESSICA HERZ, FACEBOOK’S
FORMER ASSOCIATE GENERAL COUNSEL
AS WELL AS CYNTHIA HOGAN, THE
FORMER APPLE VICE PRESIDENT FOR
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS.
KIND AN INSIDE GAME.
REPORTEDLY BIDEN HAS ALSO
CONSIDER NAMING ERIC SCHMIDT THE
FORMER TOP EXECUTIVE IN GOOGLE
AND A BIG BIDEN DONOR INTO HIS
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY TASK FORCE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
THIS IS NOT A MATTER OF
REWARDING YOUR SUPPORTERS.
IT’S IT’S MUCH BIGGER THAN THAT,
AND IT’S A DEEP CONCERN TO EVERY
AMERICAN IF WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
REAL AND FAIR ELECTIONS GOING
FORWARD, THEN WE HAVE TO END
SILICON VALLEY’S TOTAL CONTROL
OF INFORMATION.
IT’S THE FIRST THING WE MUST DO.
WE CAN’T HAVE FREE AND FAIR
ELECTIONS WITHOUT THAT.
YOU CAN’T HAVE A DEMOCRACY.
OF COURSE, THAT’S WHY THEY’RE
DOING IT.
AND THEN AT SOME POINT WE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE POLLS.
THE POLLS THIS YEAR WERE
PROFOUNDLY WRONG AND THEY ARE
PRETENDING OTHERWISE.
AS THEY WERE FINE.
THEY WEREN’T FINE.
THEY’RE LYING TO YOU WHEN THEY
TELL YOU THEY WERE FINE.
THEY WERE MEASURABLY NOT FIND.
WE COULD GO ON FOR AN HOUR BUT
LET’S SUM IT UP FOR YOU.
THEY GAINED SEATS IN THE HOUSE.
THEY TOLD US JOE BIDEN WOULD
CRUSH DONALD TRUMP IN THE
GENERAL ELECTIONS AND HE DIDN’T.
WE ARE NOT ALLEGING SOME FORMAL
CONSPIRACY BETWEEN POLLSTERS WE
ASSUME THAT THEY HONEST
MISTAKES.
SOME OF THEM ARE GOOD PEOPLE.
ON THE OTHER HAND AND THIS IS
IRREFUTABLY TRUE, NEARLY ALL OF
THEIR MISTAKES HELP JOE BIDEN.
THE FINAL REAL CLEAR POLITICS
POLLING AVERAGE HAD JOE BIDEN UP
7.2% IN THE NATIONAL POPULAR
VOTE.
THE FINAL FOR SAID HE WAS UP
11%.
IN BIDEN’S CURRENT LEAD COMES IN
AT JUST OVER 3%.
THOSE ARE BIG ERRORS.
QUINNIPIAC’S BULLS WEREN’T JUST
WRONG NATIONALLY, THEY WERE
WRONG ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
AND BAD POLLING HAS AN EFFECT, A
BIG EFFECT AT MANY LEVELS.
HERE ARE COUPLE.
IN SOUTH CAROLINA
SOUTH CAROLINA, QUINNIPIAC
RELEASE THREE SEPARATE BOWLS
THAT SHOWED LINDSEY GRAHAM WAS
TIED WITH THE DEMOCRATS
CHALLENGING HIM, A MAN CALLED
JAMIE HARRISON.
ON THE BASIS OF THAT, HARRISON
WAS ABLE TO RAISE OVER
$100 MILLION, THE MOST EVER FOR
A SENATE CANDIDATE.
SO WENT TO DONORS IN
LOS ANGELES, NEW YORK, THE MONEY
CENTERS FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND SAID LOOK AT THESE POLLS,
WE’VE GOT A SHOT.
$67 MILLION IN A STATE OF MAINE.
IN SOUTH CAROLINA, JAMIE
HARRISON LOST THE RACE BY TEN
POINTS.
WASN’T CLOSE.
IN OHIO, QUINNIPIAC’S FINAL FOR
SHOWED BIDEN UP BY 4 AND TRUMP
WON BY A LITTLE OVER 4%.
SO NONE OF THESE ERRORS WERE
LIMITED TO ONE POLLING OUTFIT.
MOST OF THEM WERE WAY OFF.
I DOES THAT MATTER?
IT’S NOT JUST ANNOYING, IT’S
SIGNIFICANT.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT POLLS
INFLUENCED VOTING BEHAVIOR, SO
EFFECTIVELY FOR ALL THOSE ERRORS
AMOUNTED TO VOTER SUPPRESSION,
AND IT’S REALLY CLEAR WHY.
WHEN PEOPLE BELIEVE THEIR
CANDIDATE CAN’T WIN AND THAT’S
WHAT THE POLLS TOLD US, THEY ARE
LESS LIKELY TO VOTE FOR THAT
CANDIDATE AND MUCH LESS LIKELY
TO SEND MONEY.
NO ONE ELSE WILL EITHER.
A STUDY BY RESEARCHERS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF TORONTO FOUND
POLLS MAY LEAD PEOPLE NOT TO
VOTE FOR A GIVEN PARTY BECAUSE
THAT PARTY IS PERCEIVED TO BE
UNLIKELY TO WIN.
WE SHOULD FIND OUT.
AND FINALLY, ANOTHER MASSIVE
SOURCE OF ELECTION INTERFERENCE
THAT WE SHOULD GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF CAME FROM OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
AUTHORITIES ON THE POLITICIANS
WHO RUN SOME OF OUR BIGGEST
CITIES.
THIS UNFOLDED OVER MONTHS, WE
CHRONICLED IT IN DETAIL BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THEY LEVERAGE THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC TO MOVE
VOTES.
NOW THAT JOE BIDEN IS THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT.
THE GREAT ORANGE EMERGENCY HAS
PASSED NOW, AND IT’S PARTY TIME.
WATCH THOUSANDS OF JOE BIDEN
SUPPORTERS INCLUDING
CHUCK SCHUMER HIMSELF SHARING
WINE BOTTLES IN THE STREETS,
SUDDENLY THE DEADLY EPIDEMIC
BEARS THEM NOT AT ALL.
>> NOW WE TAKE GEORGIA AND WE
TAKE THE WORLD.
NOW WE TAKE GEORGIA, THEN WE
CHANGE AMERICA.
>> Tucker: THEN WE CHANGE
AMERICA.
WE COULD GO ON TONIGHT ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED IN LAST WEEK’S
ELECTION AND IN FUTURE SHOWS,
YOU KNOW THAT WE WILL BUT FOR
NOW, LET’S SUM IT UP.
WE DON’T KNOW HOW MANY VOTES
WERE STOLEN ON TUESDAY NIGHT.
WE DON’T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THE
SOFTWARE THAT MANY SAY WAS
RIGGED.
WE DON’T KNOW.
BUT HERE’S WHAT WE DO KNOW.
ON A LARGER LEVEL AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS ACTUALLY, OUR SYSTEM IS
AND WHAT WE THOUGHT IT WAS.
IS NOT FAIR AS IT SHOULD BE.
HATE TO SAY THAT, IT’S THE MILK
BOTTLES AT THE FAIR, THEY KNEW
YOU WERE COMING, LAUGHED AT YOU
WHEN YOU LEFT, WE WISH THAT
WASN’T TRUE, BUT IT IS TRUE, AND
YOU ARE NOT CRAZY FOR KNOWING
IT.
YOU’RE RIGHT.
AFTER THE BREAK, JOINS US ON